well in terms of the periodic table if
this place didn't exist and people
didn't come here to work whole areas of
barely tape wouldn't wouldn't be there
now and it wouldn't be the periodic
table that we know today
so let's go to the three and we're about
to get in the car together the airport
[Music]
it's nice sunny weather in Stockholm I
don't know what to think about this I'm
getting the feeling that I can't might
be covered in snow it may take a while
to to find that car
left take the exit left take the exit
left so we have reached our destination
hi do you speak English yes yes continue
this road huh it's not much okay thank
you very much thank you
so somewhere near number 65 and then you
basically take groove again no sorry
it's called feldspar swaggin thank you
very much place now and all the locals
know of it so it must be big it must be
famous
ah it's a big river so okay so it's the
birthplace of four elements of the
periodic table it reham terbium erbium
and terbium it to be mine historic
chemical landmark in my best Swedish so
here we see it trium ytterbium terbium
erbium all found for the first time for
minerals from gadelle in height in this
quarry and we were told by a nice
gentleman down the road that we can
follow the path up through the woods and
hopefully be able to see the mine so
let's go and see if we can find it
all over so we've reached the top where
are we look up yonder left oh well we
gonna scram back there so this is
excellent for as a chemist for me to
come here to see where these elements
first came from it's really quite cool
here we can see evidence of the mining
there this mine closed many years ago
but you can see where the miners have
drilled using hand drills into these
rocks to make holes to put explosives in
to break away the the minerals so I'm
very early on 17 late 1700s a naval
officer called Arrhenius visited the
quarry and I think he may have been
prospecting for fuel and he found the
Black Rock which he thought may have
been coal when he picked the rock up he
found that it was far too heavy to be
coal coal is just simply hydrocarbon a
Chasseur carbonaceous mineral but this
rock was obviously too heavy to be coal
and he thought that there must be
something strange about it he wondered
whether it might be a new or of tungsten
which had recently been found so he
passed this material to a colleague or a
professor at the nearby arbo University
fur fur for analysis so that's where the
chemistry of the rare earths is they
recorded all the lanthanide started with
the discovery of four new elements from
that original black mineral rock yes so
we found the quarry and it's it's
breathtaking it's um surprised that we
were able to come because everyone told
us it was fenced off and closed we
didn't see any fences anyway somewhere
here there's a sign which is sort of
commemorative of this site so let's see
if we can find this historical
Mark's I I said we've now am come up the
side of the quarry into the sunlight to
find that the original plaque from the
American Society of minerals Institute
so here it says the ASM is designated
yet to be mine it to be mine sorry a
historical landmark for the discovery of
four periodic elements yttrium ytterbium
erbium and terbium and that's actually
in chronological order it reom was the
first word isolated from the black rock
and over a period of the next 40 to 50
years successive scientists we analyzed
that sample and were able to extract
both terbium and erbium initially
leading to the final isolation of
ytterbium in its purest form way back in
1950 so a period of a hundred years of
chemistry summed up in this sign from
this one specific quarry in in sweden